imagine for a second an adult man who
just pops into existence he floats in an
empty space with his arms and legs
stretched out so he don't touch each
other
he he's blindfolded and his ears are
covered basically all of his sense
organs are disrupted or doesn't work
he simply floats in this empty space
without seeing without hearing feeling
tasting or smelling anything he has no
experience of any physical objects
now ask yourself this question is this
man aware of his own existence
[Music]
this is a thought experiment presented
by the Persian philosopher eben Xena
more widely known through his latinized
name
Avicenna and what this experiment tries
to do is get to the bottom of one of the
age-old questions of mankind namely if
there is a soul that is separated from
the body a question that many Muslim as
well as non Muslim philosophers and
thinkers who were dealing with at the
time
and while the answer to this thought
experiment may seem really difficult for
us to answer at least definitely been
Xena had a definite answer in mind and
that answer was yes in other words the
man in the experiment would indeed
affirm his own existence and therefore
there is a soul that is that is
separated from the body and survives
after its death but I'm getting ahead of
myself a bit here so let's back up and
let's get to know this man who is
possibly or arguably one of the greatest
philosophical minds of all time
[Music]
i benzina lived from around 980 to 1037
ad in what is widely regarded as the
Golden Age of Islam a time when the
philosophical and scientific
advancements were at an all-time high
and have been seen I belonged to the
so-called philosopher group of scholars
which is just an era biased version of
the name philosophy really much like the
word smorgasbord is just an Anglophile
version of the Swedish word similar goes
boudin and sounds really stupid anyway
the philosopher tradition was started in
the ninth century through what is known
as the translation movement were texts
and documents from all around the world
were being translated into Arabic in the
capitals of Baghdad and especially Greek
texts so Muslim philosophers were thus
exposed and highly influenced by a Greek
philosophers in Greek philosophy
especially that of Aristotle and certain
Neoplatonic
readings of Aristotle's work many other
been seen as predecessors like al Kindi
or al farabi directly world commentaries
on the Greek classics and also trying to
incorporate those ideas into the Islamic
context or Islamic theology much to the
dissatisfaction of these so called
columns scholars of doctrinal theology
at the time who were there sort of you
could say their nemesis in a way even if
the the two groups who were sort of the
opposites the Kalam and the
Philosopher's they often very much
influenced you that each other and
inspired each other but they were never
I think admit that themselves as on the
surface they were often seen as bitter
enemies no one was more successful at
this attempt to synthesize the Greek
philosophy and Islamic theology however
then had been seen himself who sort of
can really be seen as the culmination of
the early philosophy and kalam
traditions indeed as I mentioned in a
previous video Muslim philosophies
generally divided into periods before
and after a benzina
which really shows you how great of an
impact he really had even Cena was a
polymath who wrote on everything from
metaphysics to logic Natural Science
astronomy music even and medicine indeed
one of his most famous works the Canon
of Medicine or in Arabic al Canon felt
Abe is one of the most highly regarded
medical texts of all time and was used
throughout the world right up to the
18th century and he sometimes considered
to be the father of early modern
medicine in other words this guy was
completely insane and arguably one of
the greatest geniuses of all time he was
born in Bukhara in what is today
Uzbekistan then part of the sort of
larger Persian region and he was exposed
to philosophical debates very early on
through his father he would study the
Quran and the hadith and the Islamic
Sciences and later also started gaining
an interest in the Greek classics and
other other sciences as well he was in
fact according to records kind of a
Wonder child who very early on sort of
surpassed all of his teachers and he in
fact became self-taught for most of his
life at the ripe old age of 18 he gained
status as a full-fledged physician and
started writing his earliest
philosophical texts you know that time
when you're 18 and you just finished
high school and you have no idea what to
do with your life well the patina didn't
have to worry about any of that
he tackled numerous subjects throughout
his relatively short career and I will
attempt to at least present you with a
few of these subjects for example the
question about the nature of the soul
which was one of the most highly debated
philosophical issues at the time is
handled by urban scene in a rather
unique way even if you could clearly see
the sort of theoretical framework and
the the tradition that he clearly
belongs to and is influenced by he
argues that the soul is indeed separated
from the body as shown through the
floating man experiment that we
presented in the beginning but he argues
that the soul does not exist before the
body is born in other words the the soul
is born where the body is separated from
it and survives after its death he he
rejects any physical rebirth much to the
anger of many theologians like
al-ghazali for example furthermore
another question that was hotly debated
at the time was the issue of eternity I
think we've all asked herself at one
point or another if the universe is
eternal or if it was created from
nothing at some point or like what's the
story here
it'd been Xena here takes the position
that the world is indeed eternal and
that it was not created at a specific
point in time in other words God is Co
eternal with the world now this is not
to say that God did not create the world
surely you've been seen I would not
disagree with this but his ideas a lot
more complex than this in fact it is
here in his ideas about the nature of
God and the world that he presents what
is perhaps his most unique profound and
most influential metaphysical idea it is
what a lot of people refer to as his
evidence or proof of the existence of
God a theory that at least to me is a
lot more convincing than the more famous
ontological argument by Anselm of
Canterbury for example in this theory a
benzina
begins by dividing the world into two or
three sometimes four categories the
fourth or let's say first category
that's not always included but I think
helps to gain a greater understanding is
what's known as impossible existence
impossible beings so these are things
that cannot possibly exist in the world
we cannot even conceive of them as
existing and a perfect example of this
would be a squared circle for example
this is the concept
you know that we cannot even think about
it's it's completely impossible for a
squared circle to exist nonetheless be
conceived of the second category is
contingent existence or contingent being
that is all things that we know in this
world these are things that do exist but
they might as well not exist we can
conceal them as existing but we can also
conceal them as not existing for example
this chair that I'm sitting on is a
chair right now but if I take a hammer
and I smash it to pieces it's no longer
a chair there's a possibility of them
not existing is what I'm saying
and they all have a source as well
everything comes from something else so
this I exist because my parents decided
to to to create me this chair exists
because some person decided to make a
chair the the trees outside exists
because of the laws of nature or
whatever but you can always take this
argument back it's like when you're a
child and you have an argument with
someone and you just say why you're just
it's all their question you keep asking
why and you can just keep going forever
because there's always there's always a
source there's always something that
whatever you're talking about comes from
he also adds to this category a sort of
second category that it calls necessary
existence by a virtue of another which
is more abstract that it's it's eternal
things in the world that nonetheless
have a source so this deals with more
abstract philosophical ideas like these
celestial spheres or the active
intellect and these things that they
talked about at the time the last
category and this is where this is the
kicker this is the abyss at the point
the last category is something that he
calls necessary existence by a virtue of
itself in other words this is something
a being or an existence that cannot
possibly not exist it is something that
cannot even be conceived of as not
existing it has to be by virtue of
itself it is the uncaused cause
of everything else and this fourth
category seven Cena is God and to him
all contingent beings which come from a
source and everything goes back and back
and back eventually we run into this one
thing that has always existed that will
always exist and that cannot possibly
not exist and God is the only thing that
fits into this category that to even
Cena is what God is now this is an idea
in a theory that greatly influenced
other thinkers that came after including
in DV column scholars who know if you
remember their enemies who really took
this to heart another example is the
Christian theologian very famous Thomas
of acquaintance who presented a pretty
similar argument actually about God and
was himself greatly influenced by a band
Cena on top of his other Muslim thinkers
like like I mentioned al-ghazali like
open to fail who I talked about in a
previous video I banal are abhi and
Melissa there are all these great
thinkers make direct references to even
Cena or to the idea of the necessary
existence to explain or refer to God
this I think is one of the most well
known and and really profound arguments
for God one that I myself think is very
clever in spite of its apparent
simplicity in fact I would love to know
what you guys think about it do you
think this theory is plausible or can
you poke holes to it I would love to
hear your your arguments in the comments
so please leave a comment if you have if
you have thoughts about it and keep in
mind that had been seen I was very young
when he presented these ideas I think
when he when he conceived of this
particular one he was just in his early
30s which really shows you that he was a
special human being in many ways of
course he wasn't just a metaphysician as
mentioned previously he was also a
master of logic and physics and medicine
in terms of physics he was particularly
interested in motion and an infinity and
how infinity sort of effects or has a
relationship with motion from one
point to another sore from point A to
point B for example and without going
into too much labret detail even Xena
argues that an object that is given
inclination or force will keep moving
until stopped in a vacuum in other words
if I throw a ball in space it's going to
keep moving infinitely until it meets
some resistance or or a stop by a by a
force or whatever it is and this is an
idea that was as you probably know that
was confirmed hundreds of years later in
what we today know as Isaac Newton's
first law of motion which is now part of
our great greater understanding of how
universe the universe and physics work
but not many people know that even Cena
had actually figured this out hundreds
of years earlier
[Music]
it doesn't stop here either however as
his profession after all was as a
physician he was really a master of
medicine what I mentioned previously his
book the Canon of Medicine is one of the
most reviewed and used medical texts of
all time it is it is consist of five
volumes that really summarizes all the
medical knowledge that was available at
the time the books teachings is based on
the tradition following Greek physician
Galen and it really presents an in-depth
run-through of the human anatomy of
different diseases and their causes as
well as instructions for surgical
treatment and some herbal medicine and
so on it really shows it been seen as
incredible knowledge of this subject the
Canon was translated into Latin in the
12th century and was used in Europe and
the Muslim world right up until the 18th
century in other words for 700 years
this incredibly long time for a medical
text like this he wrote some other works
as well like the famous book of healing
that deals more with his more
philosophical aspects of his of his
thoughts he really managed to accomplish
a whole lot in his relatively short life
because indeed in spite of his great
knowledge of the human body and of
medicine and so on
not even he could escape the inevitable
unpredictability of life in nature and
he unfortunately fell greatly ill at the
age of 58 and actually passed away in
1037 during their month of ramadhan but
he left behind a body of work that has
influenced the world in numerous ways he
changed the face of Islamic philosophy
and theology and influenced future
thinkers like Abe and rooster ever
always Thomas of Aquinas Rene Descartes
and and and and a whole lot more he
managed to synthesize Greek philosophy
with Islamic theology that in a way that
almost kind of ended the Great Divide
between philosophy
Calem scholars he presented scientific
ideas that predicted the findings of
Newton hundreds of years prior as well
as other scholars of the Enlightenment
and he wrote one of the greatest and
most revered medical texts of all time
all this in just 58 years as he was
approaching the end of his life he'd
been seen as thought to have said I
prefer a short life with width to a
narrow one with length and I would argue
that most certainly he lived up to those
words I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]